in this world perhaps but in my world
your world what nonsense you'll have
noticed the obvious differences between
the 1951 animated alice in wonderland
and tim burton's 2010 live-action
version but there are fascinating
secrets about how each movie was made
that'll leave you as confused as alice
herself at the mad hatter's unbirthday
party
from the little-known filming techniques
to the clever casting of each film
go behind the scenes of the wonderful
world of wonderland to discover just how
these amazing movies were created
i thought we'd settled this i'm alice
let's start with the main character and
the differences between the two
of course the films are based on the
book by the 19th century english writer
lewis carroll
in fact there were two stories alice's
adventures in wonderland
and through the looking glass in walt
disney's 1951 movie alice's age and
situation are very close to the source
material
she's a little girl who's bored and
follows a white rabbit down a hole
there she discovers wonderland in tim
burton's 2010 movie
she's a 19 year old she wanders away
from her engagement party wondering
whether to go through with a marriage
that's quite the difference but she too
follows a white rabbit and falls down a
hole to underland
in 1951 alice just wants to go home and
is fed up with all the madness but in
2010
alice is pursuing her destiny and in a
suit of armor no less
i can slay the job as for how they were
brought to life on screen
that shines a light on the differences
in filming methods the way the movies
were put together is by far the most
obvious difference between the 1951 and
2010 film
and it's not simply animation versus
live action the 1951 movie is entirely
animated of course but it wasn't just a
case of drawing pictures
the actor behind alice catherine
beaumont didn't just provide her voice
she was also the live-action reference
model that means that she actually acted
out the scenes
she explained disney often used footage
of actors to guide and inspire the
animators as they drew each scene
in the 2010 movie tim burton
deliberately opened up the creative
process and used a lot of different
filming techniques
he used motion capture green screen live
action and pure animation
this meant that shots didn't fully
manifest themselves until the end
mia vasikovska who plays alice in the
2010 movie
explained that usually you have other
actors to bounce off or get the tone
from
but with their green screen filming
she'd be doing a scene with a character
when they're not there
so she didn't know what that actor would
be giving her to react to
catherine beaumont however did have the
other voice actors right there with her
we'll have to look into this
the differences in the way the movies
were created are perfectly shown by
comparing the mad hatter
and the march hare's tea party scenes
looking at the making of the 1951 movie
we see edwin an old vaudeville star
providing the voice and live-action
reference for the mad hatter
he ad-libbed and messed around doing
things that weren't rehearsed
the animators sketched him and he made
everybody laugh with his off-the-cuff
jokes they recorded the sound as well
and actually used that in the movie
because when they got him in the
recording booth to lay down the lines
clean
it just wasn't as funny in the 2010
version it's almost like the opposite
took place
we can see johnny depp as the man hatter
sitting at the tea party table with a
young actor playing small alice
but that's it and that's because as an
animal character the march hare was
fully animated
so johnny depp had to talk to thin air
rather than another actor
he's in front of a green screen so the
different ways of creating the movie
could combine in final edit with live
action actors starring alongside
animated animals how is it you're being
so great big i'm certain she's smaller
when we met
for the human characters tim burton used
a combination of live action and motion
capture and we can see how this process
played out by going behind the scenes
with the making of tweedledee and
tweedledum
english actor matt lucas played both
twins in the 2010 movie
he was filmed in motion capture suits
for his body movements against a green
screen but his actual face was used from
live action filming i had this uh
big suit that from head to toe pretty
much that could track my movements but
my face
uh was was visible and it is actually my
face that you see on the two characters
it was very important for the director
to be able to use the real actors faces
in particular
he explained that the human characters
needed to blend in with the wonderland
world
the audience needed to see their eyes
them but in a mutated refined form
the use of motion capture suits however
helped tim burton create the difference
in size between alice and wonderland's
strange inhabitants
and of course double up one actor into
two characters
in the 1951 movie however the tweedle
twins were purely animated
they have the same kind of crazy logic
and argumentative personality traits as
their 2010 counterparts
but walt didn't have to use a body
double and cgi to place the same actor
in the shot twice like tim burton had to
someone
the red queen is another character in
the 2010 movie that was filmed using
both live action and
camera trickery techniques tim burton
used a digital dalsa video camera when
he wanted to get really close up and
really enlarge her features
the inflated head shows how tim burton's
red queen was also inspired by tenniel's
drawing of the duchess character in the
stories
she's also a combination of the red
queen from lewis carroll's through the
looking glass and the queen of hearts
from alice's adventures in wonderland
and even during lewis carroll's lifetime
the two queens got confused so it's no
surprise that many film adaptations
combine the two
this also happened in the 1951 animation
where the queen of hearts uses dialogue
from the red queen
in the 1951 movie walt used the
live-action reference process for the
queen of hearts scenes too
while she had a normal-sized head she
was much bigger in general than alice
what are the other differences between
the queens in the two films
well there's inspiration many
commentators believed lewis carroll's
original to be a caricature of queen
victoria
and for the 1951 queen walt reportedly
said that she was somewhat based on
gossip columnist luella parsons who wore
her hair in a dark bun
disney historian les perkins also
admitted that it's not uncommon for the
studio to take people they know
and caricature them in an animated film
however he then showed a picture of
alice davis who was the wife of animator
mark davis and did a lot of costume work
for disney
as for the 2010 queen helena bonham
carter revealed that she based the bossy
character on her two-year-old daughter
nell
the actor could see many similarities
between the queen and a toddler
being a tyrant no sympathy no empathy
just commands and
it's all about her wonder what nell
thinks of that now
[Music]
this is impossible there are plenty of
characters that are in both movies
including those we've already mentioned
alice the mad hatter the queen
tweedledum and tweedledee and the white
rabbit but the 2010 movie includes more
characters from the original source
material
there's the white queen who was played
by anne hathaway and there's the
jabberwock or jabberwocky in lewis
carroll's nonsense poem and tim burton's
film
and sir john tenniel's illustrations for
lewis carroll's book it's a pretty
freaky creature
and the film version doesn't stray too
far from the source but did you know
that walt disney did intend to include
the jabberwock in his 1951 animation
right up until a year before the film
was released he planned a sequence where
the cheshire
cat sings about the dragon and two other
freaky creatures too
beware the jab jab jabberwock the jubjub
and the bandersnatch
but walt thought the jabberwock was too
scary or the sequence was too long and
so it got cut
they found the original sheet music for
the cut song i'm odd and the vaults and
released it decades later
the huge dragon creature was however
included in the 2010 movie
and given that it's pretty terrifying
you can see why walt didn't think the
dragon would have sat well in the
cartoon
so walt had to cut characters but did
you know that he also added a character
of his own imagining
and that's the talking doorknob
[Music]
he was created in order to avoid a long
explanatory monologue at the beginning
of the story
but that's not the only interesting
thing about that scene we can compare
the different approaches to shooting the
movie with the scene where alice tries
to open the door
she has to grow bigger and smaller to
make it work there's footage of
catherine beaumont acting out the scene
with a prop for the 1951 version
this is an example of the live-action
reference process they used so the
animators could create believable
moments
look behind the scenes of the 2010
version however and tim burton simply
used a live action scene of mia
vasikovska trying to open the door
when it comes to getting bigger the
animators could easily draw this
difference for the earlier movie
but in the later movie they had to
create a set that made it look like
alice was big
there wasn't any cgi or camera trickery
it was just
a very small room
now that you've seen behind the scenes
has it changed your opinion about the
films
which alice in wonderland movie do you
prefer be sure to tell us in the comment
section
and hit that subscribe button to know
when we release more videos like this
thanks for watching